I believe our sound engineer Eduardo has
something he likes to say yes so is that
yes is that the correct term by the way
sound engineer sure audio engineer sound
engineer no don't work okay he said
audio engineer I think that's what
that's what you want right yeah
either is fine okay no that's not true I
could pause our microphone guy yeah
perfect uh talking man yeah talking man
has something he'd like to say how
what's what's up Eduardo I have some
exciting news to share about uh a
gentleman at this table who's going to
be making his triumphant return to the
soccer field in a couple weeks well I
know it's not me because I I never got
on the soccer field so that's not true
I've seen your remote in Mexico
so who did I play with Giovanni oh my
God that's right yes but uh but yes you
were right it's not you that's going to
be making your return it's Mr Matt
Gourley who I believe is training for uh
do you want to talk more well oh boy I
mean I I've been since hitting 50
wanting to get a bit back in shape eat
healthy and go to the gym and exercise
get my cardio and I was
uh how should I put this I know you
don't think of me as the most athletic
person and trust me I don't either Ken
it's so funny you say that because when
I think of you going to the gym I
picture a gym from 1910 and you have a
friend who yeah you have that one of
those yeah those jiggling belts but also
you throw a medicine ball and then there
are some wooden pins that you toss
around I did play soccer for a number of
years when I was a kid and and actually
played club soccer and All-Star soccer
believe it or not and I am going back
Eduardo plays and he got us on a team
called mellow yellow oh wow yeah it's
exciting yeah and uh it's in your
favorite City of Pasadena I do like
Pasadena man
Pasadena and August though uh this
summer it gets hot that's a frying pan I
know and I I am not good in the heat so
and I might not be good at soccer well
first place I encourage you to watch
Conan's remote I mean do you have any
tips for I don't remember I shot so many
remotes over so many years that uh I
have dim memories I'd have to re-watch
how many times have you played soccer
I think you watched it yeah I don't
think I really played soccer I it was
soccer was not my sport my legs are way
too long so for uh any kind of message
to get from my brain to my feet oh yeah
it takes like four days it's like a
Flintstones bit where they you know they
they hand a note to a bird that has to
take off you'd be better off shouting
the message to your feet exactly yeah uh
so I I don't remember that too well but
um yeah I was I I know that uh soccer is
not my sport although I admire it I I
think they're probably the best athletes
because they run that's what scares me
and hottest and are they oh oh well yeah
I got that I I think so them and hockey
players yeah I mean I don't understand
hockey players cover their right soccer
we are we are have helmets on yeah the
soccer players we are okay is that true
you uh I think so okay yeah that's why I
watched the world World Cup the what cup
the World Cup
[Laughter]
this show is sponsored by better help
okay imagine you're looking at a scale
with everything you do for others on one
side and then on the other side of the
scale is everything you do for yourself
the question is is it balanced I think
in a lot of cases that's probably not
the situation well guess what therapy
can help you clarify your values find
more balance in your life so you can
keep being a rock star for others
without forgetting yourself in the
process to be honest I've never been a
rock star for anybody
but I get the idea so if you're thinking
of starting therapy I think you've
better help but try here's the cool
thing it's entirely online it's designed
to be convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule so what you do is you fill
out a brief questionnaire to get matched
with a licensed therapist and switch
therapist anytime for no additional
charge and I think one of the barriers
to getting therapy for a lot of people
is
I don't know I gotta go in I gotta sit
there with this person it's going to be
awkward what if it's not a good fit
I'm gonna feel weird saying this doesn't
work for me and not coming back all of
that's eliminated uh with better help so
find more balance with better help visit
betterhelp.com Conan today to get 10 off
your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash Conan what's the
process of you getting into shape uh I I
run on a treadmill I run a about four
miles a week okay and then I do a little
bit of strength training and then I've
tried to change my diet the only problem
I haven't been able to fix is cocktails
I still gotta have my that's a lot
of sugar there's a lot of empty calories
are there steaks
do you
you compete against the other teams do
you guys win a Trope oh yeah yeah
there's a trophy but I'm nervous you
know what I found you can go buy the
trophies oh I know I passed trophy
stores all the time and I just go in and
buy them my shelves are filled with
amazing trophies
that's a big big deal here in Los
Angeles yeah so uh so what's the plan so
you're getting there I'm I'm a little
nervous because I've never been a great
endurance guy I can Sprint pretty well
and I'm tenacious mentally but I think
my body's gonna give out pretty quick
especially if it's hot so we'll see how
long has it been since you last played
soccer yeah
I've never seen you stand up no I don't
I swear to God all these five years
we've been working together and he's
always seated and I saw you once on the
sidewalk and you were in a rolling chair
yeah that's right Shuffling from an
office and you were just shoveling
yourself along I played uh like I said
when I was a kid and then I joined
soccer in high school but uh they didn't
really play me
that's usually a not a good sign it's on
your team Eduardo now how good are you
Eduardo I'm okay I bet he's pretty I bet
he's yeah he's that that means he's
really why don't you give me the benefit
of the doubt
um let me try that ask me how good I am
how good are you I'm I'm okay
um I think you're exaggerating
I'm sorry so if if one was to play
soccer does that make them hot does the
tail wagon you're back to that
um yeah I'm sort of stuck on that one
I'd like to be thought of as hot and I'm
curious if I played soccer and you
didn't know me and you saw the guy my
age playing soccer on the field in super
short shorts oh boy like really short I
think I'd be like why is his
coordination off and then because these
guys are they're running for such a long
time the whole time and they don't
they're just wearing a shirt and shorts
and like long socks you know what's
funny I'm into I would be okay with it I
would play if I could be on a pony no
one else is I'm the only one so I'm
playing Polo and I have a big like uh
like a mallet but everyone else is
running but I'm on a pony no and I mean
a very small pony like my legs are
dragging
why are you on a pony I don't know I
just I like the visual of Conan's gonna
play and he's paying for all of our
jerseys and he's paying for all the
snacks but there's one caveat he has to
be he's he brought a pony with him and
actually I have like seven ponies
because it's so hot I was gonna see the
ponies probably would pass out I would
put camelbacks on them you know uh that
bikers wear and they'll have hoses going
into their mouths so they're constantly
drinking nutritious uh Waters maybe you
could be our team manager and maybe Sona
can be our team mom and you can be the
manager I want to be I want to lose it
all the time I want to be someone who
gets to give a yellow card
yeah I'd like to be a rap and I would
just I would just be thrown I would I
would love that I would like that on the
podcast if one of you gets out of line
or says something I don't like I can
just toss cards around it needs that
kind of thing yeah I'm above the law no
you're offsides I'm on a I'm on a pony
soccer uh well I'm listen I'm looking
forward to it and maybe I'll come check
you guys out he said not meaning it yeah
soda said she'd go I well she wants to
Ogle the guy oh yeah clearly she wants
to get a look at her old co-worker in
the soccer gear that's it that's it I'm
wearing cleats shin guards and other
things that you wear when you play
soccer
no I'll come I'm close yeah I we talked
about it I know which Park you're gonna
go to too I'll come I'll come cheer you
guys on I'll chop her in okay chop her
in yeah that's Pasadena oh I can't be
expected to drive all that way I need to
call my Chopper are you gonna land the
chopper in the middle I gotta land in
the middle of the field and so many
people are gonna get cut up by the blaze
hello everyone why are people screaming
what's all this Blood about
I'm gonna land on the field with no
permit or anything and tear up all the
sod oh they do call it sod don't they
it's artificial turf for sure
I call it sod
all right well listen uh good luck to
you thanks so much and I do applaud you
on this effort to uh to get in shape I
think that's great thank you and once
you uh and trust me as a guy who
maintains himself in perfect condition
uh you're gonna enjoy it once you get to
where I am now you said perfect yep ten
ten ten out of 10. okay established hot
me over and out